muy bien ya estamos en el último jalón
de este problema ya vimos que ahí de son
verdaderas y que b es falsa así que nada
más nos falta ver si este determinante
es igual a cero y este determinante lo
copié aquí abajo para que tuviéramos
chance de trabajarlo con un poco más de
espacio así que vamos a ver que nos
queda y mira o sea como es un
determinante podríamos multiplicar esta
entrada por esta entrada y restar
restarle esta por esta y ver qué cosas
interesantes encontramos pero creo que
es una mejor idea reciclar el álgebra
que ya teníamos para obtener una
expresión un poco más simple déjame
poner a qué me refiero básicamente
quiero decir que que utilicemos que z -
z 1 ya sabemos que es que ya sabemos que
este por z 2 - z 1 deja escribo es z - z
1 ya sabemos que es igual a t por z 2
menos zeta
y cuál es el plan pues el plan es
cambiarlo aquí o sea que aquí quede te
voy a poner un poquito más arriba para
que se vea que aquí que de t por z 2 -
está 1 y entonces vamos a tener
expresiones similares aquí abajo y aquí
arriba y las cosas van a quedar más
sencillas bueno vamos a hacerlo entonces
el 13 está menos z1 pero además
necesitamos set ha conjugado menos z 1
conjugado pero la idea es que aquí ya
tenemos z menos z 1 así que podemos
conjugar de ambos lados y obtenemos que
se está conjugado - z 1 conjugado es
igual a 'the x z 2 conjugado menos z 1
conjugado a lo mejor este paso parece un
poquito mágico pero lo puedes verificar
si quieres puedes poner a z de la forma
de conjugar este lado conjugar este lado
y ver que en efecto al final las cuentas
quedan para que de esta igualdad
ahorita nos vamos a ir nada más con la
intuición de que conjugar nos permite
abrir sumas y restas vale bueno entonces
tenemos ya tenemos este término el zeta
menos z1 ya tenemos z conjugado menos
zeta 1
conjugado que es éste de acá así que
vamos a ver qué nos queda
déjame tomar el color naranja entonces
el determinante determinante sería t por
z 2 - z 1 de este lado tendríamos t por
z 2 conjugado menos z 1 conjugado y
abajo lo vamos a dejar igualito nos
queda z 2 - z 1 y aquí tendríamos z 2
conjugado citados conjugado menos z 1
conjugado ahora sí vamos a hacer este
determinante para esto hay que
multiplicar este con este este con este
y restarle el producto de éste con éste
para entonces éste te por z 2 - z 1 por
z 2 conjugado aquí es zeta ceta 2
conjugado menos z 1 conjugado ya eso hay
que restarle este por éste que este por
z 2 conjugado menos z 1 conjugado x z2
menos z 1
72 - z 1 y b esto está súper padre
verdad porque este término todo este
término es exactamente el mismo término
que el de acá y por lo tanto este se
cancela con este y nos queda igual a 0
por lo tanto la opción c es correcta y
ya nada más como resumen y esta de aquí
es correcta así que las únicas opciones
que son verdaderas son la a la c y la d